and speaking of sleeping like and people
throw that around a lot like we talk
about underrated people
speak about you know such-and-such
sleeping are you sleeping on this you're
sleeping on that
it's like it's hard to sleep on stuff in
2020 it really is
it's also hard to sleep on an nfl team
it's practically impossible to sleep on
an nfl team from new york
but i'll just be honest with you i'm not
gonna beat myself up over it too much
because it's not like they've been
exactly
you know giants but the new york
football giants man like
i mean fourth straight five and two
since that oh and five start
michael i had ignored i had written off
and ignored the entire nfc east
but a team with colt mccoy starting in
place of
the turnover machine that is daniel
jones a team with
wayne goldman running for like 135 or
whatever he had
uh in place of obviously saquon
barkley's been out since the beginning
of the year
they go into seattle and and win
and and and they're in five and seven
and they're like
why would i miss like i thought joe
judge was like uh
at the beginning of the year i was
reading that joe judge was trying to
another one of those trying to be
belichick guys and was running
the wrong way and then he fires off as a
lion coach you know kind of crazy rumors
around that like
where did this come from have you been
paying attention to giants because i
somehow
slept on the new york giants i haven't
paid attention to the giant
just like you the reason you haven't
paid attention attention to the giants
it's like everybody else
uh we look at that division and say that
division it's too much we got too much
going on
too much going on it's really not worthy
of our attention you can only keep up
with so many things that are important
and we we just dismissed uh the division
i'm shocked though more than dismissing
the division
i have just written off joe
judge i did not think he was ready to be
a head coach
i thought that this was another i did i
thought
this was another uh bill belichick
kind of want to be disciple who was not
ready for the gig
now joe judge here in new england
uh he was close he was close to
belichick belichick had a great
appreciation for him
a couple things um a couple of reasons i
didn't think he was ready
number one he's like a um
i don't know if he still talks like that
in new york but he's one of these
rah-rah
kind of like hey it's all about the name
on the front of the jersey not the name
on the back
you know all that all the cliches
like he was a candidate for a college
job and i thought that was
the best place for him i didn't think he
was a pro coach and the other thing is
he was uh the subject of one of the
biggest fights
the bill one of the biggest
disagreements let's put it that way
philosophical
arguments a verbal disagreement
between bill belichick and josh
mcdaniels why
because at the end of the 2019
season josh mcdaniels was interested in
some head coaching opportunities
joe judge was interested in some head
coaching opportunities
belichick told mcdaniels now i need you
to stay around here
didn't let him go on some interviews and
jobs kind of dried up
but he let joe judge go
and and josh mcdaniel is sitting there
thinking wait a minute
you're like joe judge he's just like
this young pup
you letting him do this where i put my
time in
you know what i mean it's almost like
the uh it's like
wait a minute it's a seniority thing
don't i have seniority
why are you asking me why are you
forcing me to stay and do work and miss
out on interviews
and you letting the kid go in there and
get the job
and that on top of that he wrote a
personal letter on behalf of joe
judge to the giants belichick did this
is the guy for the job
he came highly recommended i didn't
think he had
enough on his resume to do a good job
for example
he was the uh wide receivers coach last
year in new england
uh the wide receivers are terrible um so
i
i was looking at him i thought he was
more sizzled than substance but
i was wrong substance is there 18.9
points per game they've given up
uh in this five and two stretch since
that 0-5
start and you see you're seeing words
like or hearing words like culture
uh being discussed around this team
you're seeing buy-in
you know which is which is most
important so it's like i love the story
because of like process
and it's like they weren't seeing the
results early on in the year
but they believed and they hung together
they hung tough and it's like
this future or even their present their
present and their future
both look bright i do want to pivot
though if i may michael call a quick
audible let's do it and just stay in a
division
just a standard division um because once
upon a time carson wentz was the
unquestioned
future of the
well actually no hold on i'm not going
to win [ __ ] i'm not going to win i
skipped a big part of that story i'm
sorry i go to wins in a second i got
ahead of myself
um yeah talk about your season sometimes
i'm about to say
sometimes i wish jason johnson came on
on a monday i don't want to see i don't
want him on a wednesday
when it's subsided bruh okay do you
trust us do you trust the seahawks now i
mean
the giants near me or not be good do you
trust them
you're in my head you're in my head the
the word
i was thinking this is like and don't
ask me why i was i was awake at
1 30 2 o'clock 2 30 in the morning just
thinking about some stuff
and the word i was thinking about then
and a word i was thinking about an hour
ago
was true trust trust and everybody
was just talking about they had smooth
sailing the rest of the way
to be a top the top seed in the company
that is
that's the word for december
most teams have played 12 games
somewhere in there 11 12 games
and so this is where you figure out with
another
month of games you'll you'll know who
the contenders are
when you ask your yourself the question
do i trust them
do i trust them in big situations so i
trust them to perform
uh up to their potential teams that
don't perform up to their potential
consistently
are not championship teams they're fine
they might have some talent
but those are the teams that get
eliminated uh in in wild card weekend
or or collapse down the stretch the
seahawks have the talent they have a
great quarterback
and russell wilson well overall mike do
not trust the team
i don't trust that's but wait a minute
they do have a great quarterback
and we'll and i'll get to another one
that's the victim of this as well i'm
not putting it all on russ
but i believe he's got the most
turnovers in the league since week seven
it's like can we can you trust russ to
take care of the football at this point
that's a scary thought it's like if
you're not gonna trust the seahawks
you say okay i don't trust the defense
and for the most part this year plenty
of reason not to they had a secondary
look like they were getting it together
on that side of the ball
i was like okay i don't trust that
defense i don't trust the running game
fine
you know injuries guys shuttling in out
in the lineup
you know but i can't trust russell
wilson is something that
you don't want to feel but the facts in
front of you
suggest that there's reason not to even
trust the quarterback at this point
and so you know we've been up and down
with them i just went off this roller
coaster earlier in the year it was like
russ's mvp
had it to him you know it was a lifetime
achievement award
this season was going to be his training
day you feel me like
you're gonna get the oscar for this
movie you were great but you should have
gotten a long time ago you never got any
mvp vote this could be to you you get
the mvp russell wilson and then i'm good
at it that goes what is this team
how good are they though i mean we're
talking about all the trust i mean just
talent-wise
across the board they had some injuries
i think everybody has everybody's
dealing with covid
i mean when you say how good do i think
they can emerge from the nfc
right now no i don't think they're
better than green bay
i don't think they're better uh then
i don't think they're better one on
division they're definitely not better
than new orleans
you know oh you think the rams are
better right now
i trusted more i take the rams it was
about that word trust i trust the rams i
look
every things can change every week
that's the nature of this league
but i'd say i trust the rams more um
all right we'll see because the rams the
rams have a game this week rams have a
game in a few days on thursday thursday
night football so
who they got where we got thursday you
know the patriots
oh there you go all right uh home game
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3-5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you